I am so fascinated by the idea of this
movie because I'm such a big nerd when
it comes to the business of film and
with the Chinese box office taking over
from us this year probably does that
fascinate you as someone who is both the
producer and an actor in your career
thinking about the idea of these
co-production it was exciting to be the
first huge one you know that was really
fun yes because we had a hundred
translators on the set like it was just
I don't know how it was it was chaos I
mean in a really good way and but you
know we had a lot of experience both on
the Chinese and the international side
like we always made a lot of movies and
so it was this fun thing where we we had
that language in common right the
language of moviemaking yes but you know
it was this really fun like kind of
cultural experiment was it like on set
because at the moment when your
character and Pedro's characters talk to
each other like have you ever seen
anything like this incredible and I was
like that's probably what they say to
each other watching the the number of
extras in full battle armor I mean you
know and those guys would have to get
there at 4:00 in the morning and like
get ready like it's beggared the
imagination you just want like oh my god
like this is huge this is like being a
necessity to mil movie there was
literally a day that we saw a piece of
the set and I wonder if it's in the
movie they take us up in an elevator and
we're in the kind of like the belly of
the wall and he's returning you know
wheels and only CEO all the inner
workings of it and we were like little
dorks yeah you know like we're gonna go
you know like pointing and like you know
it was it was that kind of that kind of
experience this is the biggest film that
you've undertaken what was the greatest
challenge in putting it all together
totally you go the biggest challenge is
actually to bring two cultures together
to find commonality longitude goes from
character development to story
development something that both sides
will understand and our interest of it
and it can't get too complicated
it can't get too crazy about those life
so you've got to be able to let go of a
lot of preconceived notions to bring
both sides together this is
huge logistical undertaking like even if
you just done it straight you know
Mandarin crew Mandarin speaking crew or
straight English speaking crew it was
the biggest movie I've ever been a part
of so yes and I think we all felt lucky
that we got to be the first ones to try
[Music]
[Music]
you